good morning today is Sunday for us and
a lot has happened first thing first Mia
come here girl you're not Mia
Mia oh you can't hear okay so my
girlfriend is limping here we took her
to the vet yesterday it's nothing crazy
nothing serious other than so little
doggies they have their pads right um
and what happens is when they're walking
on hot gravel or they're walking too
much or they're walking on extremely
cold floors or gravel um in the snow uh
when their pads get dried out like
there's so many different
circumstances why this happens but Mia
cracked her paw um and it's normal it
happens um you do want to put bomm on
their paws I don't know I never had any
other dogs that have this I don't know
what's up with Mia this is the first dog
I've ever had that this has happened to
but it's also the first time that I've
had two young pups young dogs with each
other with a big ass backyard and they
[__] play all the time so I guess it
was expected but yeah her paw cracked
and um we think it's because her and
Cooper just keep going back and forth in
our backyard and they just go zoom zoom
zoom zoom zoom and they run like crazy
and it's been about a week now and um
it's not healing it's not closing so we
took her to the vet had them clean it
well first of all we had them checked to
make sure that what I was thinking it
was was even it cuz I'm just speaking
out of my ass I'm not a vet obviously so
yeah they checked her out nothing
serious that they can see right because
we're not doing the X-ray route or
anything like that but they were looking
at the ligaments doing a bunch of tests
they think it's the Paw crack as well so
they cleaned it they bandaged it up and
the only reason why she's wearing the
cone of Shane right now is because she's
obviously going to one and all at that
cute that they put pink and it was also
really sweet Mia I'm sorry girlfriend
I'm so sorry and it was also really
sweet that I got to show you what's
going on in the room to everyone's like
we love Mia she's so sweet we don't want
to give her back and I'm like I know
she's the best um so yeah that's the
first thing that's happening the second
one that you guys just saw I don't know
why I'm numbering it now this is
specifically for the Cooper and yes I
know Cooper can just jump here and get
on it but I'm just making his life hard
I don't want him all my furniture no on
anything this is what he's been
doing this he chews on
everything this he chewed on the outside
of our house let me show you my so he
chewed on one of you can go out because
I I don't want you got to stay in meia
went out first he was chewing on this
and he chewed this luckily we got our
Grill painted and they did all the
stuckle and they did all this stuff to
it so this is an
addition here so because of that they
had extra paint they had that extra
stule stuff so I told the guys I'm like
if it's not too much trouble and you
don't get in trouble I'm like is there
damn rhyming um can you please fix that
for me cuz it was literally just like
here that he ate and he ate here and
they did it they fixed it so yeah this
guy has been on a nibbling chewing
destroying frenzy and I feel like he's
just at the cusp of out of it so once he
does I'll take all those chairs down
um oh she's pooping all over my you're
pooping you know you're not supposed to
poop there and I trained them dude
there's so much going on hi welcome my
life has been very eventful these days
okay so the other one is the dogs are
all they're trained to now where she's
going thank you it's like she heard me
talking [__] and that's where they're
supposed to be pooping so they've been
trained to go
there and I don't know why she just
pooped on this side she's not supposed
to but anyway um our yard is about
90 90% done ordered all our furniture
that's in route I think I just got
delivered maybe two rugs one here one
over there um and within the next couple
of weeks we excuse me we should have
everything
here um what else is there this they
gave us these rocks they filled it with
these type of river rock that were more
like in the red tone and I'm
like I'm sorry that doesn't work it
looks
horrible um so they took that out and
that was the only time I've actually had
them change anything CU for the most
part they've done a really outstanding
job of nailing our vision back here so
they took all those out and they're
going to put a White River Rock and I've
been waiting now for like a couple weeks
but whatever I mean it's just rock um
once that's done then we're pretty much
concluded in the
backyard yeah so the river the White
River Rocks will cover all of this and
it'll run all the way here and then this
will start spilling over that's why you
see like these
grates and then this spills into the big
pool
okay A lot's going on okay and then over
here we got Papa measuring cuz this is
where we're going to have have our gym
we're moving our gym outside of our
garage cuz it does feel a little bit
cramped there
now um we put a patio
cover so this is
where our gym will be so he's measuring
it now to get some
mats this will be all mates back here
we'll have squat rack squat cage we'll
have
dumbbells treadmill and all our other
equipment F perfectly here we might even
have space to roll out our Jiu-Jitsu
mats and do some
Jiu-Jitsu um and then we're going to
block out so you see that guy our
neighbor over there you see his green he
has like this mesh covering so his is
green we're going to get one you give me
a favorite step on that corner we're
going to
sure we're going to do black here just
so it matches and then maybe here we
might cover or maybe not I don't know if
I care that
much but yeah that's what's happening
here oh let me show you the
front so and then we got this installed
before we installed this was this little
tiny door and we wanted it to be if we
wanted to ever Park any cars or any
off-roading
toys we could easily open this and then
start back here we expanded our
driveway we added this big old tree
that's now going dormant cuz it's
getting cold when we got it it had green
leaves but now it's season change uh we
added Turf and then we're going to start
adding a lot of plants here adding a lot
more plants cleaning everything up
they're going to start taking everything
out here we planted some roses oh there
they are look you see one
pretty little white
rose so these will grow pretty nice nice
and
Tall um yeah that's kind of it that's
kind of it for
now yeah okay so
now there's been a lot going on know I'm
saying check out ta's
room his room is a
mess oh boy
Boy Buddy oh buddy oh
buddy what you got a lot of cleaning to
do my
friend but we'll T we'll worry about
that later put on some shoes let's go
get some beees B baby let's go baby yeah
we're going to go get some breakfast and
then since it's Sunday we do our Sunday
reset so we'll wash everything organize
everything and get everything started
for Monday we'll clean out our fridge
wash our clothes reorganize restock do
all of that [__] but for now we pretend
it doesn't exist we're going to go get
some breakfast cuz we don't ever do that
on the
weekday and I think we're going to one
of my girlfriends just had a baby so
we'll go get that stuff you know present
for her and welcome the new baby and
then we'll go get the
mats and it's a really cute pet shop in
the outskirts like out in the boonies
what I think is the boonies cuz it feels
like it's so far out from where we live
and the strip and just
civilization um it's a horse shop should
already tell you a lot um yes we'll
probably go get the M but it's such a
cute shop um and I can't wait to share
that with you but yeah let's go okay so
it's some breakfast time now and check
out this spot it's so cute there's so
many little shops here but look look at
how pretty this
is look at
this it is so
[Music]
[Applause]
nice so pretty and we're eating
here at the Daily Bread look at
this I love
this oh my goodness the food has arrived
so I'm a very simple keep the breakfast
small I don't want to eat too too much
so I just got avocado toast H 17
[__] dou what what did you just
say
nothings on it too I look really good I
am never a fan of avocado toast but the
S has your mom's uh famous onions on
there I kind of want buy have a little
buy no and then you got thank you oh
thank you and then you got I got corn
beef Dam I love these potato I love
uneven potatoes that's just going to say
and have corn beef hash and I love it's
all uneven like this and look at this
bread they bake all their um bread and
pastries like fres I bogged it and then
ta got this really good this right and
it's crazy good yeah it's just bread I
love bakeries like this m and then which
I I get lemon blueberry pancakes o la la
Jona that's bab yes sir and Can I some
of course
sh the whole so that avocado H toast was
bomb they had like onion in there thank
you so much I'm going to grab you a
straw to than it was
limey so it's really bomb finished it
now I had to get that pistachio than you
so much look at that
delicious what' you get straw uh
raspberry danish and it's so fluffy like
look it's like air light oh look look
look how air light it is yeah yeah
you guys done fighting no
jeez okay so these guys are done
fighting I goofed up it's not a horse
store that we're going to get our mats
they didn't have it there so we're
getting it at a tractor store tractor
supply store this place is also
Cy let's go inside I think they have
like little ducks and stuff what is this
guy doing I never know what this guy's
doing
got okay
got so we are inside and the first thing
I see now that we have plants cuz I want
to get gardening
stuff uh I don't know what half of this
stuff is for I'm just kidding I'm
totally just kidding but I do want to
get whoa
this is some slasher
[__] I actually don't know what I want
to get so I'm going to just look
around and
see what I want to get and I'll check
back
in all right so we got it we got ta
getting into the cart but so far I've
picked up copper or yeah copper Fung
side and I noticed one of the one of our
trees I don't know if it's the lemon or
the lime tree is getting some weird
looking thing on its leaves so I'm going
to spray that on on it see if that gets
rid of it we're going to get some fruit
tree fertilizer this one is for citrus
and avocado or fruit and nut trees so
it's like really good um fertilizer to
help it grow faster and um healthier and
then I'm getting allpurpose plant food
cuz we just have a bunch of different
plants out there that I would like for
them to grow up faster and healthier and
look really really pretty pu's getting
me some shears do we need something this
big just for the palm tree I think
that's enough this one yeah I don't know
what else I would need that for until
our trees get really big should we just
get it just we have it
nope all right Papa you just had a
really good moment what just happened
I'm a fan of Tractor Supply so growing
up in the west coast you know since
they're all pansies out there all we
really have is Home Depot and Lowe's and
we don't have like the real wheel and so
like every single like hose um organizer
like pulley thing that we've gotten it's
for like the posers so all the wheels
pop off all the time I'm pulling it on
gravel things fly off I'm like they got
to make something legit like if you want
to pull something in and out of the
backyard this looks legit and I saw this
one and I'm like of course a place like
Tractor Supply would have it look at
this it's really ugly though it is but
it's going to work and even the beefiest
one we have at home I was dragging it
somewhere and the wheels popped off
already that's the beef is one I'm like
okay you know what then we only need one
we don't need any other hose we don't
need two hoses you do need two hoses no
I'm not going to this is not going to be
parked there this is going to be parked
off to the side what are you talking
about what are you talking about I'm
talking about I'll let you know what
we're talking about so we have the front
and the backyard right we both need
hoses chill chill so the backyard one
couches are going to go right there
where that the the adapter is right yeah
yeah so this we would have to wheel it
in I'm not going to have it be there
where the couches are that doesn't make
any sense that's ugly yeah you wouldn't
do that yeah I'm going to wheel it you
actually lived where people do stuff
like this the hose would be attached
there but you would have it stored
around the corner so it doesn't affect
the aesthetic but every time you want to
hose there is no around the corner you
want to go attached it's a pain in the
butt yeah but there is no around the
corner where the uh cool supply stuff is
we would just have the hose running
below it's going to mess up all our
plants no no no around the
house you don't weave it through the
plants you put it on the ground so that
when you need it you turn it on and you
have a host it's it's it's honestly I
have no idea what he's talking about cuz
I don't see where I know this guy is not
the Aesthetics guy trust me you do not
want to you want to be able to turn on
something and have correct I agree with
you I'm just saying I don't think our
current layout is going to allow for
that is what I'm saying so what do you
want you want to mount it on the
wall I would not want to I'm just saying
we can just wheel it in and out that's
what I'm saying D if you have this
parked in the front yard and you need to
rinse real quick in the back you to run
to the front yard to wheel it all the
way back back into the backyard or just
have two set one in the back one in the
front but just not attached yes that's
what I mean no you didn't you said
having it weaved one and the front I won
this is doing anything in the back this
is what it is Gio one point but it
doesn't give a [__] I don't really
either but it always feels good to be
like I love you
dude
okay so I ended up getting both of those
um we'll see how it works worst case
scenario we don't like the way it looks
I don't like the way it looks and we'll
just return
it we are gotten some old doggy toys
doggy chew toy man Papa your butt is
button look at this butt is
button and now I'm looking for like cage
or some sort of barrier that I can put
in front of the pool to prevent Mia from
getting in since she gets in so easily
and freely we can't use a doggy door
because we don't want a wet dog inside
of our house so let's see if we can find
[Applause]
something this way we go to the
left go to the
left so now we're in downtown suland to
pick up my girlfriend dang he went
far simp baby clothes for our new
nephew okay so I can't wait to show you
all the C little baby stuff I bought um
I'm going to make like a little basket
and I got the big sister something too
but look at what Papa got not ta Papa
not taica show them what Papa got a
burger a stuffed it's a big stuffed so I
love love Burgers is my first favorite
food ever and I went on a quest in high
school to find the best tasting burgers
and I would get like at least once a
week yeah and I loved it so much I also
went on a quest of getting stuffed um
animal burgers so I used to have a cell
phone cover that was a burger remember
when back to flip phones you would tuck
the top part in the top and the bottom
of the other one it's in a shoe box
somewhere to find it and then one of my
old school friends Nina she knew I like
burgers and she got me another stuffed
burger that was like this big and I
completely forgot that that was a thing
that I loved stuffed animal burgers so
when I saw that I was like oh that
reminds me me of like my not childhood
but like my teenhood I was I want to get
that and put in the office cuz it brings
me so many happy memories and what' you
get look how big it is it's big as a
body look what you get look got this
Sweedish fish sish how do you earn this
one being a so right now he his animal
is a kangaroo so in school every time he
does good deeds or he does something
good they get reward points and it's
like a punch card so uh depending on how
many like there's like different levels
of animal the better you do with the
punch card the higher you move up in the
animal kingdom I guess so right now he's
like in the second tier so he's a
kangaroo which is pretty good he already
went up two levels so I told him you
know what we can buy this but it's not
yours so what he has to do is we're
going to keep this at home every day
when he becomes a what do you have to
become
monkey when it becomes a panda then it's
his so it's at home but it's not his so
that's how he has to earn it you got it
dude so we all took a nap we think te
took a nap we're not sure
but we'll just say he took a half nap um
we're all up now T not taica well taica
senior is over here jior I like that
it's not Bart Juni it's ta Senor yeah
he's
assembling this yes ta he's taking a
deuce
what you need toilet paper you need
toilet
paper uhoh you're going to have to just
use your hand dude
e monkey you're just going to have to
use your hand you have to I'm not doing
with my hand you're I'm doing your hand
no way dude see you later mama need all
right all right I'm coming my kid kind
of smart I'm not using my hand I'm using
your head you think he's smart boy you
think he's smart boy no coopy coops
you're the best coopy coops I've known a
lot of Coopers in my life I think you're
my favorite
one good
boy
I totally
forgot to Vlog last night okay so Joe
and Hannah um ended up coming over last
night and um we hadn't seen them in a
long time or I hadn't seen them in a
long time since they've been um living
out in Hawaii right now building out ji
and stuff and Joe will fly out to
California to film J and you so it was
really nice to catch up with them and I
totally forgot that I said that I would
show you what I bought at the kids store
um for my friend who just had a baby so
keep in mind this is her second baby so
she essentially has everything the first
baby was a girl this Baby's a boy um but
she does have a lot of gender neutral
clothing and just a lot of the items
that you tend to keep for babies tends
to be gender neutral and if it's not
it's not a big deal and she's really rad
where she's like I don't need a a boy
high chair you know what I mean
so um I just got her a couple things cuz
she literally has everything um that I
thought was cute I picked a neutral
theme I don't know why I've been into
neutrals maybe I've been brainwashed
into just liking neutrals right now but
I'm I've been on a neutral for this past
year like give me Tans give me Grays
what just keep it neutral I love it so I
kept that theme going here and let me
show you what I
got okay not the most flattering angle
but we're going to do it so I got him a
little baby teether look at this
um teething is a huge thing when it
comes to babies let me R this a little
bit um it causes them diarrhea a lot of
discomfort lack of sleep like it just FS
them up so if I can give them anything
to relieve that I will so this is a huge
one and then pacifier a must so you can
already see the theme here and it's just
so cute because I wanted it to go
with this so this is uh oh did the tag
fall off oh no it
didn't it's a knotted gown and he'll be
able to wear this as he grows so I think
it goes from 0 to 4 months um it's
really easy access especially cuz these
babies are eating and pooping the whole
time that you don't want to be it's just
so tedious to get them in and out of
um of the little onesies so if they
don't explode out of their diaper then
this is rad because it's just easy
access boom you have access to the
little little dirty nappy the little
dirty the little dirty diaper and it's
easy to put on and to take off and the
material is so soft I wish you could
feel it super
soft the color is so cute I think it's
great high quality high quality okay I
feel like I'm selling this to you guys
and and going back to the
teething when Tao was teething he would
have to wear two of these cuz he would
drool so much it would go on his clothes
like it would soak this up and then it
would go on his clothes so these bibs
are super duper thick and again neutral
okay and right here these were my
favorite favorite they are pricey um
but they were my favorite with taica and
it's um by magnetic
me instead of the buttons y'all it's
magnets I was like I got to change you
real quick put him in put him in boom
done he's changed and then they have
some really gnarly claws or they just
have no control of their hands so you
can cover their hands see my hands I
don't see it again neutral
but bam we need some of these clothes
and then bam you don't even have to
think about it just snap
together let's go
okay and then you can't leave the other
kid out of it you know so I got her a
little book I'm not going to pull the
tag out but it's for her to learn sounds
and words um it's my big book of nature
sounds so she'll press it as you know
they read it to her and it's super
interactive really fun on it says more
than 100 sounds so I thought she would
really enjoy this just because she
really loves to read um and yeah look at
that it's so pretty so then she'll
associate this with the picture on this
side and boom yeah so that's what I got
her okay on that note I have to finish
packing cuz today we're going to
California cuz we're celebrating barbell
brigade's 10y year anniversary we're
going to have like a little get together
for that free tacos music lifting
contest different different contests
with
prizes um then on Sunday we're going to
go to the hundreds family fest where
they
bring to it's like a festival where they
bring all of these really dope
restaurants um and they just have a
different like just different events and
things but the main focus is really bomb
food so um we're going to go out to
support our friends Ben and Bobby hund
out there um and enjoy some really bomb
food so Hub vlogging all of that
so let's get into it but for now thank
you so much for joining me all my day um
and I will see you tomorrow bye